IT'S NOW TIME TONIGHT FOR THE
HASHTAG WARS.
OSCAR NOMINATIONS, OR OSCAR
NOM NOM NOMS, WILL BE ANNOUNCED
TOMORROW MORNING AND YOU
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS, BIG
HONORS, BIG SNUBS AND A BIG
PART OF AMERICA GOING "THE
[BLEEP] ARE THESE MOVIES?"
WHERE'S BEST PIC FOR
TRANSFORMERS.
THOSE ARE THE RAZZIES -- BUT
IN HONOR HOLLYWOOD HE A
BIGGEST DAY WE'RE SIZING UP
THE HASHTAG WAR WITH
#BiggerStars.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> EXAMPLES WOULD BE, SAMUEL
XXXL JACKSON.
OR DWAYNE "THE BOULDER"
JOHNSON.
OR ARIANNA VENTI.
(APPLAUSE)
IT'S A THINKER.
IT'S NOT A THINKER.
I WILL PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND GO.
ARI.
>> DR. MARTIN LUTHER KING
SIZE.
>> CHRIS: OKAY, POINTS.
NICK.
>> OBESE WITHERSPOON.
ROB.
>> R.BELLY.
>> CHRIS: OKAY, POINTS.
ARI.
>> ROB RIGGLE TO GET INTO
THESE JEANS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NICK.
>> FAT DAMON.
>> CHRIS: OKAY, POINTS.
ROB.
>> GIRTH BROOKS.
>> CHRIS: OKAY, POINTS.
NICK.
>> REALLY HUGH JACKMAN.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. GENIUS.
NICK.
>> MICHAEL EATON.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
ROB.
>> SIX PACK SHAKUR.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, POINTS.
ROB.
>> HARRISON CAN'T FIT IN A
FORD.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, POINTS.